there's a moment when you say to  yourself  it can't be done  but instead of backing down  you push yourself forward  into the unknown  you don't want to shooting extraction  too we're back  with a title of two behind your neighbor  you have to bring at least twice the  action  where the landscape is ever evolving  where everything that got you here  doesn't mean a thing unless you can do  it bigger and better than ever before  for extraction one we had a major action  sequence that felt like one continuous  shot we call that a Warner for  extraction two we're going to push that  even further with a sequence more  intricate and more extreme than before  he's got a real helicopter landing on  the rooftop of moving trains  it's pretty damn exciting  I'm very proud of what we've done end  result is going to blow through your  mind  Against All Odds  find a way to make the impossible  just another Target  [Music]